ainsley take it away all right thank you
brian chicago's mayor lori lightfoot
says chicago police will be vaccinated
as the union fights the mandate listen
number one cause of death in 2020 of law
enforcement was covet 19 nothing else
it's foolish
foolish
to be trying to take a victory lap
when so much is at stake
but unfortunately that's in keeping with
the leadership of this fraternal order
of police they will be vaccinated
this as the city sees yet another
violent weekend with 40 people shot
three killed since friday here to react
is president of the chicago fraternity
of police john katzenzara good morning
to you john
good morning good morning what's your
reaction when you hear her say police
will be vaccinated
well it's rhetoric we've heard from day
one the irony is
she talks about our officers that have
died from covid
thankfully we haven't had an officer
pass away for almost a year now so
clearly we've adjusted to our new
reality this isn't diminishing their
memory because we will be having a
formal memorial for those officers we
lost last year at the fop this week but
for her to talk about officers who died
in the line of duty is disgusting she
has no credibility on the topic and she
should keep that out of her mouth
well yeah she's worried about people
dying because of kova but what about all
the people that are dying because of all
this violence on the streets in chicago
just this weekend alone 35 shot three or
four i've read four killed i've heard
three as well but still these are
people's lives
ainslie we have had 185 expressway
shootings in chicago this year
185. that's just the expressways
the violence is out of control and the
superintendent and the mayor keep trying
to say there's a decrease in the
increase of the decrease it is absurd
and i could tell you we know we will
have thousands of officers who are
willing to not get paid to not get the
vaccine and this isn't just the
fraternal order of police like she keeps
harping on this is the sergeants
association the lieutenant's association
and the captains association united in
this fight that our members should not
be forced to get a mandated vaccine and
that's for all the city workers if they
refuse to get the vaccine how many did
you say would probably be affected
you know we don't have exact numbers but
it's
roughly i would figure about 3 000 if we
go with the the informal surveys that
have been done so far well if they don't
get vaccinated they're not out on the
streets protecting the community so the
people of chicago are affected
absolutely and the violence is only
going to get worse and this is a
department that is lost to retirement
and leave of absences to other
departments almost 900 plus officers so
far this year already we can't afford
more officers off the street we just
can't john thank you for everything you
do